Oh,
we're back.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the fleshlight.
What is that?
What's the flashlight?
So it's a thing.
You fucking deal with that.
It's a sex toy.
Yeah,
it's embarrassing.
but it works.
If you're interested,
go to Joe Rogan Tab.
Now.
Click on the length of the flashlight
and I run the code named Rogan.
Get yourself 15% off.
All right.
They been our sponsors
since back in the day.
Since the snowflakes in the background,
if you are interested,
go check it out.
If not,
that's cool too.
We're also sponsored by onnit.com o.
N N.
I t,
makers of Alpha brain.
Uh,
we also make a,
a bunch of different supplements for a
health and wellness and for cognitive
ability would alpha brain is,
is a nootropic.
It's my favorite of all the
supplements that I take.
Um,
if you go to a on a.com o n n,
I t l,
it'll explain everything,
all the ingredients,
what it does.
Uh,
don't just look at that though.
Google nootropics find out about the
pros and cons if you're interested.
But what they are basically his vitamin
supplements that enhance the way your
brain produces neurotransmitters.
It enhances your brain's ability,
it gives you all the building blocks
for all the stuff that makes your brain
work well.
And uh,
I knew someone that I got you.
I got you Rick Ross.
So,
um,
go to on a Dotcom,
O,
n n I t a check it out first the first
30 bottles if he is a controversial sort
of a supplement and we want to make
it as as clean and easy as possible.
So the first 30 bottles you buy is a
hundred percent money back guarantee.
You do not need to return the product.
All you have to do is say
that this stuff sucks.
That's how confident we are in it.
That you got to like it and
you got to keep ordering it.
It's a staple in my diet.
I take that shit every day.
I just took three right before this
meeting cause Rick Ross is here and we're
about to get busy.
This is going to be interesting.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Strap yourself in.
Here we go.
Okay,
good.
Yeah.
Well.
Good experience
my day,
Joe Rogan podcast all day.
Ladies,
Ladies and gentlemen,
we're going into the rabbit hole today.
This is going to be an interesting one.
This is going to be a
weird one we have here.
Former aspiring tennis star.
Is that true?
Really true.
You were aspiring tennis
star was a tennis star.
Yeah.
This is a,
a man who eventually went on to become
probably the most famous drug dealer in
the history of Los Angeles.
I would say that's as
accurate as you can get.
Yeah.
You're the most,
I mean,
you're not the United States
if not the United States.
It's right up there though.
The most famous,
the most famous.
Yeah.
You got a dude stole your fucking name.
No,
no,
no.
Like three people stole my name.
Sure.
Three people.
Three people,
three rappers or three a
different drug dealers wrappers.
Uh,
let me see.
We know the guy who was probably the
most famous out of all of them is William
Roberts who goes by Rick Ross.
Uh,
do we use the wrapper
that it is a corrections
officer?
Correctional officers.
How hilarious is that?
Anything?
He's the best gangsta
rapper ever embedded in.
And biggie.
That's nonsense.
And then we got my man who's cool,
who I'm cool with,
you know,
and I don't mind him using parts of,
my name is freeway out of
Philly and we also have a,
it was a freeway rich out of Kansas City
that did pretty good in the Midwest.
Um,
there are also some guys right now out
of a Ohio who go buy it and then with the
freeway boys.
So that's four different,
uh,
groups that have taken my name in on my,
you know,
parts of my persona and use it.
Well,
one of them got very famous though,
very famous right now.
Yeah,
that's fascinating.
And you know what's really weird,
it's kind of weird too,
you know that to show him,
write his name and identity and in
claiming as your own in their background.
Well,
what's Hilarious,
I'm going to,
I'm going to send Brian a link
of where he talked about it.
He had,
he'd come on us,
dude show and uh,
the guy asked him about it and uh,
his,
his reasoning response was so stupid.
It is,
it's amazing the guy is successful is as
successful as he is because he was like
you.
No,
no,
no.
That happened like 10 years ago.
I got that nickname.
I wasn't even about that.
Like the fuck can I answer is that it's,
it doesn't even mean when you know,
you know that the dude exists,
you know?
I know.
Okay.
I'm a white standup comedian.
I know who freeway Ricky Ross is.
You don't know.
And you're a fucking corrections officer
who became a rapper and you're in that
world and you don't know who Rick Ross
is and you just happen to have his
fucking name.
Well,
you know,
the guy,
one thing,
I got to get a guy and he's,
he's powerful.
He didn't put some moves together.
Now that he's getting courts and
everybody to do what he wants them to do.
So whatever he's doing,
he's damn good at it.
I mean,
you know,
to have the judge to rule in his
favor the other day was like really,
really ironic to me.
I could not believe that
somebody could say that.
If somebody steals something from you,
no matter how long it is,
that it takes you before
you catch them and can,
can bring them,
uh,
to the jurisdictions,
attention.
How could they say that the
statute of limitations had ran out?
That was just so crazy to me.
How do you have a statute of
limitations are in your name?
And that's what I was saying.
I mean,
if somebody steals something from you,
it takes you 10 years to catch him
with it and you catch them with it.
It has all the,
all the makings on it that it's yours.
How could you not be made to give it back?
You know what I'm saying?
And you saying,
oh,
well he had his 10 years,
so now it's,
he is,
well,
what's really crazy is
that it's in the mode.
I mean,
wrap the world of rap is supposed to
be the most legitimate world ever.
Like you can't get
caught with any bullshit.
You can't get caught faking anything.
Do you get caught faking anything?
People will turn on you like that.
I'm used to be like that
minimum lyric.
Yeah.
He bit somebody robbing
my lyric and you are done.
You know?
Remember Nelly Benelli I mean those guys
last night [inaudible] Nelly,
Nelly Minelli.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well those guys were
really rappers though,
you know,
but I mean still doing the time of,
of,
of genuine,
real yes.
And now I think that that the time has
changed so much and it's not about real
anymore.
It's about,
uh,
faking it,
you know?
Well,
it's,
once someone gets popular enough that
they bypass the underground hardcore fans
and they make it into the mainstream and
then they become a part of pop culture
like this,
every [inaudible] that just got into the
mainstream culture because the words in
between that they're not good.
No,
it's not.
He's not a good rapper.
It's that every day I'm
hustling is just so good.
You know,
when you hear that in a club you like,
damn,
that's good.
You know,
it's just such a good
hook that that made him,
I mean,
that's where it all took off from.
Exactly.
And you don't,
and you have universal behind you pushing,
you know,
they started pushing stuff
down our kids' throat,
you know,
and next thing you know,
they'd taken it.
That's fascinating.
So he's got your name now.
So now it's legal that he's got your name.
Well,
why didn't he use his own fucking name?
What Rick Ross,
is it just a name?
You know what I mean?
It's not like star child beyond the grave.
You don't have like
some crazy fucking name.
You know what I mean?
What's his name?
His real name?
Uh,
William Roberts.
What's wrong with Bill Roberts?
I don't know.
How about Bill Roberts?
I'm ready to wrap Rick Ross.
I mean,
if it was raw,
sounds like you guys
tells you real estate,
you can be like on one of those,
uh,
those billboards that they
have on the bus stops.
You know,
Rick Ross [inaudible] face.
If my mom would have
named me William Roberts,
my name would be William.
Robert.
Yeah.
Yeah,
you'd be fruit freeway will Robert.
Exactly.
What's wrong with that?
Well,
you know,
hey man,
we can't hear you in the background.
There's no microphone.
Even,
even that,
uh,
everyday I'm hustling
is something that I had,
I used to say he got that out of a book
that Gary Rep Worldcon dark alliance and
you know,
I was telling Gary then
I'm hustling everyday.
So he took that into a song.
So I mean,
you know,
I don't know what it is with this guy.
You know,
he tattooed my name on his hand.
That's so strange.
I mean,
I'm going to do,
that's so strange.
It's a little weird.
And he used to be a corrections officer,
which is really fucked up because
to become a corrections officer,
they going to do a
background check on you.
Oh Man,
I make sure you're not a felon.
Wiki clean.
Yeah.
You can't,
you can't be this gangster dude and
be a fucking guy who was a corrections
officer.
We should get his application and read
what it says and what it takes to be a
correctional officer.
All the,
uh,
criteria.
Yeah.
How about the pictures of
him with the outfit on?
You see,
I saw it.
It's ridiculous.
I started with the smooth face.
What's really fucked up
is there's a video of him,
uh,
an old video of him and
you're on the video,
you're on the beginning of it.
And then he comes out like he
knew who the fuck you were.
He put you in his video,
right?
Yeah.
But he said he didn't know
who I was under oath the too.
How do you not bring that video
and just stick that in his face.
And it should be case quote.
What a judge didn't want to see that.
Whoa.
So this is the judges getting bribed.
Must be,
I mean,
you know,
has to be,
it looks funny to me.
How can he,
how could you,
it has to be bribery 100% that
that judge should be in jail.
There's no,
there's no doubt about it.
That's your fucking name,
man.
That's your fucking name.
I mean,
and let this guy come in court and say
that he never heard any of her hurting
me.
That's hilarious.
And how he invented the name,
you know,
it was like,
wow.
You know,
he gave us some elaborate story to,
well hell,
you've rented what?
I heard him on this video.
It was so stupid.
He was like,
no,
the name came bro.
Look 10 years ago.
Like what does that mean?
What does that mean?
It was like a non answer to
the question and it was just,
and then he tried to like beat passed it.
The question,
just talk about people just like to talk
a lot of shit and start a lot of shit.
And I'm like,
what?
Yeah,
he likes the Bolo.
He liked the bolo.
People
come in and you know like either
you're going to do the interview to,
you ain't gonna to do the interview.
I ain't gonna talk about this.
You know,
I'm going to talk about
what I want to talk about.
Oh,
I see.
So he doesn't just come in and
just have a conversation with you.
He comes into like with
a specific set of rules.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I think most of his interviews
or rehearsed and written down,
you know,
the way,
I mean,
the way they seem like to me,
you know,
I mean everything about this guy,
it's,
it's a suspect.
You know,
when I was in jail,
somebody wrote me a letter and said,
hey,
his beard is fake.
Okay.
Could you imagine this chick
black cotton balls on his face?
Yeah.
This chick wrote me and said,
oh,
his beard is fake too.
I mean,
you know,
it's just so much stuff and you know,
you hear and people,
you know,
shooting your messages and in,
in all kinds of stuff like that there.
Man.
A matter of fact,
a couple of weeks ago I get a call and
it was a guy that was in jail while he
was a correctional officer.
You said,
here's the story.
She hit a story.
This guy,
well,
they have to say,
what is her?
Oh Man.
He said this guy was one of the
worst CEO's that you could be.
You know,
he was one that CLC
already doesn't have power.
He has to go to his boss
and tell his boss on you.
So he said that this guy was running
around and all sneaky and trying to hit
what they talking about.
And if they shoot dice and he'd run
up and tell his boss ain't down there
shooting dice boss,
let's go.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's the kind of guy they use using for.
And then like when they do rates,
you know when they Rachel sale,
he would be the first one they push in.
You know,
the big,
the big fat guy.
You know,
cause everybody be kind of
scared of the big fat guy.
So they would all get behind him
and shoved him up in the sale.
So all this big blob of meters.
So he was the battering Ram.
Yay.
Oh that's hilarious.
Wow.
It's so fucked up.
Did that guy got legitimate that all
of a sudden he's a legit rap star man.
It's fascinating.
It's fascinating how that snuck by,
you know?
Well,
you know,
I,
I people just let him
slide them on in their,
the owners,
you know,
and slowly and slowly he was accepted.
You know,
it seems like that can't last.
It seems like,
you know,
rappers have a short shelf life anyway.
A lot of them mean there's dudes like Jay
z and Nas that we'll just stick around
just cause they're so
talented he can't stop them.
But a lot of rappers,
they,
they come for a little while and
then I kind of think this is,
this is going to take wind
out of his sale eventually.
Well,
I dunno,
you know when,
when,
when those people put labels,
put that money behind you and,
and you become made their money cow.
You know,
they have a sense of,
of,
of just shoving you
down everybody's throat,
you know,
keeping you on the radio in
anything people hear on the radio,
you know,
they believe it
or at once they can get money out of you.
They know that keep
getting money out of you.
So they just use you as a cow.
They just use you as a cow.
So they keep milking you
and keep milking you and,
and,
and it's going to be up
to the people to say,
you know what,
when,
okay,
how many times you shoved
this guy and I face,
we're not buying.
You know,
we know he's a correctional officer.
We know he never sold drugs.
You know,
he's a fake and we know he sold,
he stole Rick Ross,
his name.
It's got your name tattooed on his
body and we want him to give it back.
You know what I'm saying?
That's what the streets
need you to tell him.
You know,
get Rick back is fucking man.
I'll give him back his fucking name
if it makes me feel any better.
He was on a TV show and he left his hat
there and our friend Tom Segura stole
his hat and he wears it every,
every day.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
That's beautiful.
Yeah.
Tom,
who was excited though.
I want to talk to you.
He's a standup comedian.
Good friend of mine.
Now your story is you were aspiring
tennis star and then you went on to make
some women than neighborhood roughly of
like $600 million from selling crack in
Los Angeles in like two years.
I did that.
That was my last two years.
I don't know before that
I made a lot of money,
but for those two years,
what's really crazy is that
this all has a connection,
not just to Los Angeles,
but to Ronald Reagan and Oliver
North and the contras in Nicaragua.
This is what a lot of people don't know.
There's crazy conspiracy theories
and people always talking about,
Oh man,
the CIA sells drugs and,
and then you know,
uh,
Lee Harvey Oswald didn't act alone
and we never landed on the moon.
And when you talk about conspiracies,
people go,
what the fuck are you talking about?
You crazy asshole.
You really believe the CIA sold drugs?
Well then fucking,
yeah,
they did.
Not only did they sell drugs,
Michael Rupert exposed it when the CIA
director tried to come to watts and have
this big meaning to try to prove,
I remember that.
It's a bad motherfucker
Mac line.
Uh,
uh,
let me even in the own
investigation though,
to CIA admitted that,
knew about it,
that their operatives of selling drugs
now Dan reports to fund the contras
because the congress had cut off funding.
Absolutely.
So they needed money to fund the contras
war against the Sandinistas who are
backed by the Russians.
And this was during the Cold War and
they were supposedly worried that the
Russians were going to take over.
Nicaragua was of the,
there was an idea that
that was what they feared.
Uh,
you know,
I read a couple books on it after,
after I found out at the story broke,
I wanted to know more about
what I was involved in.
And what they feared is that the
Sandinistas basically Russia had gay,
the Sandinistas like a hundred million
dollars and congress had cut off all
monies to the contrast.
So they had to figure out a way to,
to,
to raise this money to defeat
this army that had $100 million,
you know,
back then,
I guess a hundred million dollars probably
would be equivalent to $1 billion.
Right now today.
So they were looking for ways to,
to,
to raise this money.
So what they decided to do
was sell weapons to Iran,
convert that money back to
Nicaragua to these guys.
And these guys could take that money
and going by drugs that way it wouldn't
leave a paper trail back to the u s and,
and that's basically what they did.
And that's what got exposed with the,
uh,
the Oliver North trial.
And that's what Ronald Reagan had to
get on TV and said he couldn't remember.
Yeah.
I couldn't remember whether or not
they sold arms to people who hate us.
And then,
you know,
two in the carry investigations,
they told him to stop right at the drugs
when they started to go into the part
about the trafficking
in the cocaine they had,
it's not the hearings.
Why did they have the
hearing stopped right there?
I don't know.
US too to inflammatory.
Yeah,
I guess so.
My,
my documentary is going to explore that.
a producing director for my
documentary was sitting there in the,
in the Senate hearings.
So He's bringing all those tapes and
they were going to put document are going
to come out.
It's not coming.
Should be out in like
November of next year.
And we hope that now,
did you find out about this
connection between the countries,
the southern,
eastern,
all this while you were in jail?
Yes,
I was in jail was in 96.
So you have no idea
about the CIA connection?
No,
I didn't care man.
I was just trying to make money.
You know,
I was a a kid in south
central and I was illiterate.
I couldn't read,
couldn't write a,
and I found out that,
you know,
my tennis career was basically over
because I couldn't go to college.
It was no way I was going to college.
Where were you playing tennis,
you know,
like tournaments and stuff.
Yeah,
I played tournaments,
southern California tournaments.
And you know,
when you play those tournaments,
you don't have to turn
in your report card.
You know,
you just go out and play.
They don't ask you that.
I also played high school tennis and,
uh,
I had dreams of going to college and
playing college tennis and all that was
derailed.
Uh,
you know,
when it was discovered that
I couldn't read or write.
Wow.
How did you get through schools?
You couldn't read or write?
They just pass you.
Yeah man.
You know,
teachers,
they don't really care about
if you get in your education or not.
And for sure at that time,
and by me being a,
uh,
a good student,
I guess they just kind of like felt they
were doing me a favor by just let me
get through.
But being a good student,
how can you be a good student
if you can't read or write?
Well,
I didn't cause him any problems some,
so you were just dealing with a wild
bunch of kids and you are a nice guy,
right?
Sit in my seat,
you know,
probably go to in class most of the time,
you know.
Wow.
You know,
don't call the teacher no problems.
if it was time for me to read,
I would,
uh,
go to principal office,
get my squats.
So being bad in class
that day and you know,
the next day I'd come
back and go back to sleep.
Wow.
Isn't it amazing that the standards are
so low that all you have to do to be a
good student is not be
crazy and a problem?
Exactly.
You don't have to participate at all.
That's amazing.
And I never really participated in class,
you know,
none that I can remember.
Well,
I've always said that the number one
problem with this country for sure is that
we don't care about other people's kids.
We don't care about how other
people's kids are growing up.
We don't care if it's not your kid.
That's,
that's illiterate.
If not,
it's not.
Your kid is growing up without a father.
It's not.
Your kid is growing up in poverty,
doesn't know where their next meal is.
You don't give a fuck.
But meanwhile you give a fuck about
what's happening in another part of the
world.
You know,
freedom of Afghanistan and all this
nutty shit that went on in Iraq.
It are real.
War is with the our own people
that we have to live with.
Our own national community.
A national community has six spots
and these six parts of the ghettos,
and it's real simple.
If you're,
you're,
you get unlucky roll the dice and
you're born in that sixth spot,
well guess what?
You're fucked.
You got to figure out a way
out of that somehow or another,
but the odds are long against you,
long against you and
that's a real travesty.
It is.
We as human beings concentrate on some
shit that's going on in another part of
the world.
It's not even connected to us and we don't
concentrate on people that work about
fucking coming contact
with has been in bill.
Yeah.
Spending more than that.
Trillions and we're not concentrating
on the people that were really going to
come in contact with the people that are
going to grow up and be a problem with
everybody they interact with because their
life is fucked from the get go and be
a problem for your kids.
Just imagine,
you know,
in a few years your kid is walking down
the street and he run into one of these
kids.
They exactly,
I didn't get it,
you know,
and you'd get robbed there.
Your situation is so crazy.
It's so hard to wrap your head around.
You know that you,
you were involved,
you were like a part of this gigantic
machine and you don't even know about it.
You just won't.
You just were trying to sell
crack and gave me a some money.
They gave me a way out.
You know,
you look at how did it start?
How do I start selling?
Yeah.
Oh Man.
I was sitting on my porch one day and
I was so broke and one of my big homeys
call him and he say,
man,
I got the new thing.
I said,
Huh?
He say,
man,
come over here right now.
So I jumped in my car at old 66 Chevrolet
and I throw a dollar worth of gas and
then I drove to his house.
It might have been my last dollar.
Right.
Wow.
I'm like,
wow.
I put my last out in the tank.
I'm through now.
So when I get to his house,
he,
uh,
he laid it out,
you know,
it was cocaine,
and he was like,
man,
this is the new thing.
And I saw the movie
super fly and I'm like,
wow,
super fly.
That's me.
You know,
not always wanted.
When I saw fly,
man,
I just love that movie.
You know,
when,
when it's hilarious now
they try watching it now.
It's Kinda hilarious.
Yeah.
I might have to do that.
You know,
when I,
when I finally bought my first VCR,
just the way they're dressed,
the way they talk,
he goes,
my hall,
my vines,
he goes,
this is all I ever wanted in life.
My whole,
my vines or white woman like you,
my hall.
Like that's what these,
they call their cart.
My vines was his close,
you know,
it's like the nicknames were hilarious.
The ones that didn't stick,
I haven't watched that
since like 82 or something,
man.
Wow.
We,
when I bought my first VCR,
I mean,
that was the first one I had.
I threw it right up in there.
Whoop.
Wow.
Okay.
So,
so you,
you go over your friends house,
he's got it all done.
This is crack or this is
not just cocaine or crack.
It's powder.
Yeah.
Right.
But uh,
he's cooking it in the rock at that time.
Now who,
who taught everybody to cook it?
How the fuck did that come about?
Because that to me is a massive mystery.
There's someone figured out how to
take cocaine and turn it into a more or
addictive,
it was already guys
cooking it when I started.
Right.
But it was only a few of them but it's
free base is different than crack,
right?
Yeah.
Freebasing Richard prior had a freeway
but it's still the same product.
They would cook but they were
just taking coke and cooking it.
How were they doing it?
You cooked it with ether.
Oh.
Which was a much more difficult process,
but it's still the same product.
Technically.
The only difference is that uh,
with with free base,
I mean with,
with,
with what they call crack
cause we didn't call it crack.
We called it ready rock ready rock.
Yeah.
We call it ready rock.
The differences with ready
rock cause you use baking soda.
Now what I did is in my neighborhood
was three guys that could cook it.
These guys were very expensive,
very,
very expensive to cook it.
So what I did is once I learn
how to cook it from these guys,
cause I kept watching them do it over
and over and over again and they keep
charging me for the cook three grams,
they might charge you
$175 so I'll keep paying.
How is three three grams cross?
What is it?
Three grants back then?
Three grams would have been about $900
so at a $900 you're paying 175 bucks.
Pretty Pricey.
It was.
It was pricey for what they did.
It took them 10 minutes,
15 minutes.
Getting the coke is the hard part.
That's really hard.
But then you got to cook it up.
So you know,
that was another part.
But once I learned how to do it when
I did is I just started showing all my
little friends how to do it,
you know?
So that became like a job for them.
They could just cook and make,
you know what other guys were charging?
175 they could charge 125 and and,
and you know,
and just sold a market though.
It's weird that coke is expensive,
but crack is not [inaudible] not true.
That's a misconception.
There's a misconception.
Big misconception.
Crack is expensive.
There is no crack without coke.
Right?
So if you took a Kia coke
and you cooked it in a crack,
the price don't drop.
So what,
what is the benefit?
Price goes up,
the price goes up.
You make more money.
Do you need less to get high?
Is that what it is?
No,
no,
it,
it don't really have anything
to do with the high c.
If you spend 40,000 for a key or powder,
you still got to get at least
40,000 for the key or cooked.
Where people think that it's cheaper than
some misconception that they have put
in people mind that that rock is cheaper.
No,
no,
no.
It's still the same key of cocaine.
You still have to get
your money back out of it.
If you spend 40,000,
you still got to sell
that rock for 40,000.
Okay.
What is the benefit of
turning it into rock?
Done?
They can smoke it.
Yeah.
Is that better?
It's a better high,
they say then,
then,
then smoking powder.
Is it a,
do you need less of it
to get high that way?
Uh,
no.
So No.
So there's no benefit financially go
in the way of crack or post to coke if
you're
no,
you're fucked up.
Take powder and put on their pipe,
it's going to burn different.
He said it turns the
pipe all black and gooey.
Uh,
but rock it took all the
impurities out of the coke.
So now you're just
smoking pure cocaine and,
and,
and they liked that better.
And that's what the baking soda,
that's where the baking
Soda Baking Soda did.
Check our holes,
the impurities out as much.
Right.
It cooked all the
impurities out of it and,
and turn it into a jail.
Now you,
you,
you meet this guy,
you go over his house,
he's got the coke and you know,
you decide,
all right,
this is it.
This is what I'm gonna do.
I'm going to be super fly.
Now look,
did a light bulb go off in your head?
Not Unbelieving,
man.
Really.
He showed me some was about the size of a,
I'm one of those little match hasn't told
me it was worth $50 this is my boy too
though.
You know,
it's my boy.
Right?
If it had been somebody else,
I never would've,
I wouldn't even touch it.
But this was my boy telling me this.
He said,
man,
that's where $50.
I'm like,
wow,
come on,
Mike stopped it.
$50 man.
The police would never catch me with that.
You know what I'm talking about something
so small you could barely see it.
You know,
I can put it in my fingernails and he
tells me that's where $50 in and I just
spent my last dollar on gas and now you're
telling me that this little thing is
worth 50 so I can make my money back.
What's $40 and he gave it to me.
He'll take it and go,
wow.
So,
uh,
you know,
I go and I'm going around trying to
figure out what is it really coped,
you know,
so I'm going to everybody in the accident,
an accident,
nobody really knew what it was.
What year was this?
79 and [inaudible] 79.
Beginning of 80.
Now in the 80s.
For people who don't know,
I,
uh,
I was living in Boston at the time and uh,
I remember when crack hit and it was,
it was like a wave of
crime just took over.
It was weird.
It was like a real noticeable increase
in crime once crack had become a part of
the culture.
Well,
you know,
when,
when people start smoking cocaine,
they going to do whatever they can to,
to keep that high going,
you know,
beg,
steal,
borrow.
You know,
I mean,
it was something about it where they
said was so joyful that you never want it
to stop.
Wow.
Some,
some guys who just said was the best
sensation that didn't ever happen.
You never fucked with it.
I tried it about one week,
maybe week and a half for a whole week.
Yeah.
Damn.
Was this in the beginning?
Yeah.
Gaining.
I caught myself early.
Know I went through a phase where,
you know,
we thought we had came up
on some money and then,
you know,
I thought I was rich.
I had about 10,000 and then
all my friends are like,
man,
come on,
let's smoke.
So I mean we'd,
wow.
And I am the good thing though.
I'd never smoked weed before in my life.
That's a good thing.
It was at that time.
Yeah.
So that,
that probably what helps
save me from becoming a,
an an an addict
so that you weren't used
to smoke and things.
Right.
I wasn't used to smoking.
I was a tennis player,
you know?
Right,
right,
right.
You were healthy.
I was healthy.
So when I started smoking,
you know,
started putting the lacing in in the
weed and smoking and then I looked up,
my money was like,
wow man,
you,
you had 10,000 you down to like
500 now.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
That quick,
that quick.
It was going to quit.
Stop.
No,
no,
I just quit.
I said,
man,
this ain't what you went
into the game for it.
But was it difficult physically?
Did you have a withdrawal?
No.
Withdraws?
When you have a strong mind,
you probably pulled yourself weak,
you know,
I think that's all it takes.
I did,
I did it for about a week and I never
felt the addiction like I did the baking
soda thing where,
how often did you do it for that week?
I probably did it twice.
Three times.
Two Times a day?
No,
no,
no.
I mean three times for the whole week.
But I mean,
I was also doing a lot of cocaine
at that point and I never got,
I never liked the snack.
Is it a,
some people get addicted to,
some people don't want to let you know.
You gotta you gotta pull yourself and
you got to find a reason why you want to
quit.
Right.
See some people,
you know,
like I got an uncle,
he's been getting high
since the day I started.
And you know what he tells me what?
Quit.
Wow.
What am I quit for?
We had a friend who was a comedian who
was a heroin addict who wound up dying.
Mitch Hedberg.
Very funny guy.
Really,
really funny dude.
And they tried to stop him a few times.
It's like,
bitch,
I ain't stopping shit.
That was his attitude is this is me.
I mean a person should be allowed to do
whatever it is with their life as long
as they don't hurt anybody else.
Infringe on your rights
that they want to do.
I agree 100% now you're,
you're sitting there,
you're,
how old were you when this happened?
When I started?
Yeah.
1820 1920 so you're 20
you get started in it and then how
do you go about going from that to
everything?
Branching out to you be in the biggest,
most famous guy
was,
it was,
I guess you would say like an evolution,
you know,
learning process.
You know,
the first time I learned that first piece
of cocaine I got and I got beat out of
it.
Another one of my big
homies beat me out of it,
you know,
told me they met him,
tested and let him smoke it.
And you know,
it wasn't big as a match head.
So he cut it in half and he smoked a
piece of it and he was not going home.
That's the way they used to do.
You know when they smoke it and smack,
they Lipson taste some let me know.
I need another piece though
to make sure it's good.
You don't want to go
out and sell a nun name.
Right.
Chipped it again.
And the whole thing was gone and it
was a little teeny weeny piece left.
And he's like,
man,
I'm going to go and smoke that too
and then I'll just pay you Friday.
Ah,
pay you Friday's never happened.
Never has a hamburger today ever.
It never,
I never got that 50.
Never.
We probably never will those,
those,
I'll pay you Friday guys.
They never,
they don't.
So that was my,
uh,
business in the cocaine.
So right away you wouldn't,
okay.
I got to be a little more
prudent with my fucking,
my resources here.
It started in the end,
it right there,
right?
Yeah.
I felt like my career was over because
how was I going to go back to Mike and
telling my man,
I'm going to go tell my man,
man,
I ain't got the $50 man.
Wow,
I want to re up,
but I don't know how to 50 but uh,
what happened is,
is that guy who beat me out to 50
and he taught me another lesson.
He come right back that day
with somebody that won $100.
See,
like with,
with,
with people who use,
if they owe you,
then they'll come when they bring
somebody else with them and say,
oh man,
this ain't my money.
It's his money.
Okay,
that's hilarious.
So he came back with somebody
wanting to buy $100 worth.
And I called my man.
I said,
man,
I ain't got your 50 but uh,
somebody else want to buy
$100 but for you won't it?
And he shot over there serving that.
And next thing you know,
this guy who beat me out to 50,
kept bringing person after person,
after person.
And next thing I know
I'm making $200 a day,
$300 a day,
but now I'm giving all
the money to my man.
And uh,
you know,
one day I was just like,
man,
I'm going into business for myself.
So how did you get a distributor?
We're started just like that.
I started off just getting it from him.
And then,
uh,
I've been,
talking about going to Venice skill
center to do upholstery and me and this a
teacher there,
they taught the class had become really,
really good friends.
We played tennis together and,
um,
I just stopped going around him because
I spent all my time selling coke.
And,
uh,
one day I go down,
you know,
just to see him because this was
my man and I hadn't seen him.
And I said,
man,
uh,
how you doing?
And he's like,
well,
what are you being mad?
I was like,
man,
you don't want to know where been right.
So,
uh,
I went on and told him,
I was like,
man,
I've been a,
I've been selling coke.
You know what I'm doing now?
He's like,
what
mommy?
So he had a whole different attitude
and I thought he was going to have,
but you know,
he was flying and you know,
I used to like his little jewelry and he,
he'd do a brand new cat bag and all that.
Right.
So he said,
man,
come by the house.
So I go by the house man.
And he laid it all out.
He's like,
man,
you think I got this house,
this Cadillac,
these clothes,
and like this here on a teacher salary.
No Way.
He's said,
man,
I traveled the world.
He said I should sell coke,
but I just backed up for awhile.
Whoa.
So,
uh,
it's hard to do that,
right?
Have the Nicaraguan connection.
Yeah.
You gotta be really,
really strong.
The backup without going to
prison or getting killed.
It's very few people do write.
Very few do.
I don't know.
Not One person that
just quit on their own,
I don't think,
when I was going to prison.
Wow.
That's amazing.
So,
so this guy gets you the
Nicaraguan connection?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He called his guy up,
man,
and
he's guy was like,
I'm from Nicaragua.
You know,
spoke broken English
and gave me some prices,
man.
And it was like all love.
I was like,
man,
I'm going to be rich.
Wow.
So,
um,
are you familiar with how they got
it into the country or at the time,
did you know how they were getting into?
Nah,
I didn't care.
I wasn't that big.
You know,
you're 20.
I'm 20 years old.
Never had nothing.
You know,
I hadn't had it.
I had never had $1,000 before
I started selling coke.
I don't know if I hadn't
had ever had $500.
You know what I'm saying?
Right,
right,
right.
So I'm just thankful that
I'm in this position.
I ain't asking no questions.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm like super fly.
Don't ask no questions.
And long as the man that you've eaten,
man,
leaving and long,
you know,
and that's the way I was.
That was the attitude I had.
I was just going along with the process.
Wow,
that's a,
that's,
that's gotta be a crazy position to be in,
man.
To all of a sudden it starts taking
off and you see it and then you're just
rolling in this money.
I mean,
it really is like a movie,
right?
Did it feel like I'm moving to you?
Like all of a sudden you go
from being broke to just pause.
It was not a dream.
You know,
you,
you feeling like,
you know,
finally,
uh,
God had recognize you,
you know,
all this time,
all this time you had been ignored
by God and now all of a sudden,
you know,
all the things that you prayed for and
hope would happen in your life had just
taken place.
Wow.
That's a crazy way to put
that God had recognized you.
That's how it felt,
you know,
honest.
You know,
I felt that it was a
blessing from God that,
uh,
then I had been putting
that position and now,
you know,
my family wouldn't have no more hungry
nights and we wouldn't be worried about
the lights getting cut
off the gas and you know,
those roaches and rats when going to
be running through the house no more.
Cause I was going to get some,
some uh,
rat traps and traffic rid of them,
you know,
and we're just gonna
pass them hoes up in the,
in the cabinets and you know,
all the things that,
that I regretted when I was a kid,
you know,
standing in line with food,
Sam's all that was over with.
Did you learn how to read it this time?
Nah Man.
I didn't know how to read.
I went to prison.
Wow.
That's amazing.
I was forced to learn how to read.
What did you do with the money?
Like how'd you bank
man?
I had big safes.
I had safe.
So they come out the Queen
Mary Way 2,500 pounds one time.
They stole my safe on my house.
I said,
they'll never do that again.
You know,
this dude put me up on these saves
that it took like a little train track,
the rang through and
wow.
They wasn't moving at bill professional
safe moving and moving them up at your
house when they stole
the safe on your house.
How much was in the safe?
Yeah,
and I think,
I think one time he
got like maybe 180,000.
160,000
wow.
And cash in a safe and you
just weren't home or something.
They knew when you were leaving.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They knew probably was an inside job.
Of course.
You know how that go on
in your family members.
She opened the door and they're crazy.
It's crazy to think about it,
isn't it?
Yeah.
So then you got a big,
giant safe and he kept it all in and say,
you mean you had to be
locked out at all times?
If you have that kind of cash around,
you're not dealing with banks at all.
Like,
oh no,
no,
no.
I didn't go to no bank,
man.
Why don't my mom,
she used to take,
cause I had a couple of properties in my
name and my mom actually let her go and
collect all the rents,
my section eight checks.
And uh,
she was used to just throw them in the
bank because I paid the mortgages and
stuff.
I'm adult money and uh,
the,
the bankers used to say,
tell your son to come in and
Smithers
he's doing pretty good in real estate.
Wow.
That's hilarious.
So did you come up with a bunch of
businesses to sort of mask your money?
Yeah,
I had,
I acquainted,
I had um,
I had a custom time wheel shop,
carwash,
shoe store,
a beauty salon junk.
Your Moteo bought a old t eight or,
and I had apartment
buildings all over the place.
I used to build apartment buildings.
That was like one of my hobbies.
Did you have to show how you got the
money to buy any of these businesses are
started in these businesses?
I figured out how to,
yeah,
man.
You know,
people taught me how to launder the money.
Right.
How you go to the bank and you,
you get the cashier's checks and you know,
so we figured,
you know,
we figured it out,
how to get around it.
No.
All this time you couldn't read.
That's amazing.
So when you went into the banks
and fill out the paperwork,
how did you do that?
Well,
I would just have somebody
else to do it for me.
You know,
like if I'm buying a piece of property,
the real estate agent
would do most of the work.
Now I've had times where they told me
one thing and it wasn't what it was,
you know,
so,
so those are the chances that you
take when you can't read or write.
Wow.
Like one time I had a
building that I bought in,
they told me that the note was going to
be 3000 a month and old turn out to be
6,200 a month.
So it cost me like 3,200 a month
because I couldn't read the contract.
So I mean,
it's costly when you
don't know how to read.
That's incredible that you accomplished
so much without learning how to read.
That's,
that's amazing.
Well,
you know what I felt is that I
had developed a sense of people,
you know what,
I could feel good people
and bad people just,
just,
just sensing them who,
who do,
who to deal with and who not to deal with.
And,
you know,
you make some mistakes,
but you know,
overall I think that,
uh,
you know,
I did all right with some of them.
So as long as you are making them money,
everybody was making money.
Everybody was happy.
Yeah.
You know,
I pay for a need a
baker's first album too.
Wow.
Seriously.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
Finance Beverly Glen in music.
Uh,
oldest Smith
was the owner of the label.
Rest in peace.
Uh,
he used to take care of
me when I play tennis,
you'll buy me tennis shoes and rackets.
And so when I came up,
I ran into him one day and he
wasn't doing all that well.
So,
you know,
returning the favor.
Oh Wow.
That's beautiful.
But he got his 10 fold,
you know,
they say you get a ten four he used to
buy me a tennis shoes in a rag as I gave
him 600,000
wow.
So you know,
sometimes you do a good deed,
they come back to you.
It might be,
you know,
took,
took 10 15 years,
but
so how did it all come apart
man?
It was coming apart from the beginning
right away.
It was just crazy.
Yeah.
What winds up happening is,
you know,
they created this task force
called the freeway task force.
Yeah.
That was these group of
officers just to go after you.
Yeah.
You're a freeway.
Ricky Ross.
Yeah.
They said that my name was
ringing so much downtown.
The city hall had a special meeting.
Wow.
I said,
who is this guy in south central making
all this money and everybody and stop?
Because what I found out is when I finally
got arrested is that not that people
wouldn't really telling on me right.
To get me in trouble.
They was bragging about me.
He had a homeboy wick.
He eats millionaire.
He got this,
he got that.
He wasn't the whole hood,
you know.
So this is creating a hysteria
downtown and they're like,
well,
who is this guy?
Why is everybody talking about him?
And what I found out,
these guys are in jail
talking about me to,
you know,
like they sit in and holding tanks and,
and they having conversations
with my freeway,
Rick.
And so the guards are hearing
this and they go and report it.
And so now everybody wants
to know who is this guy?
Imagine if it was Rick Ross,
the fake record
cross
Rick Ross.
And when a reporter,
you imagine we find that shit out.
Hey,
I mean that's a goddamn
connection right there.
We might've fucking
found the magic bullet.
Ah,
that's hilarious.
So they hear about you through legend.
You just,
you'd just become,
now are you aware of how famous
you are at this time in a shale?
See my guys know that ain't,
you can't talk about me and you talking
about meeting your girls and nobody
could tell him what none of my business,
right Dane in our business,
they don't need to know our business,
but
it wind up getting past the line.
You know when you got that line,
but it jumped over that
line and everybody knew.
Yeah,
it became public.
You had no idea.
I had no idea it was public.
You thought you were just like,
like a cat hundred of the couch and
you think you're hidden but your tails
poking out.
You know,
they think you could see him.
He like,
it's,
I see you mine,
you are mine.
And that's what I was living under.
I was living under that illusion that,
that nobody knew who I was because
I didn't drive the fancy cars.
You know,
I could walk in a restaurant
and nobody would spot me.
Right,
right,
right.
They wouldn't be pointing
on that go wreck over there.
So you kept it low key.
You stayed in the same house.
Uh,
you know,
I had houses all over a bunch of houses,
a bunch of houses,
but they wasn't,
you know,
I level didn't get you get a match it,
it's nothing crazy.
Right?
Pasadena estates with giant
lawns and fountains and shit.
None of that,
right?
Yeah.
Not nothing like that.
So I worked through,
what else I found out though is that I
see my guys have become so big in their
own rights is if they mentioned your
name one time to their little workers and
then their workers run out.
Oh man,
the homie Rick took care of us.
Okay.
And these guys words were so powerful
that they would only have to mention you
one time.
You know,
they like,
uh,
I guess you would call them almost like
evangelists and that you keep having
these type of guys mentioned your name.
Then the next thing you know,
your name is everything.
This is all what you summarized once
you've got into prison and really sat down
with all the time in the world
to analyze what was going on.
How long did it last?
How many years did you
sell for eight years?
Eight years.
So you're 28 when you got arrested?
Yup.
Wow,
that's crazy.
So you had lived so long
career for a drug dealer.
It's huge.
Yeah.
Most of my friends who,
who started,
you know and got big two years,
three years and they go home.
What kind of car were you
driving and try to stay low key.
Yeah
man.
I had a Ford Ltd station wagon with
the wood grain on the [inaudible] side.
The little bird.
Yup.
You know,
little funeral home bird.
Wow.
On the side of the windows.
I had in 1981 of this,
well wait a minute,
the funeral home bird,
did you have that on purpose?
You put that on there.
So it looked like a funeral home car.
He had the police pulled
up on the side of that.
They looked the other way.
Nobody wouldn't look in that car.
That's,
that's hilarious.
So it was almost like a hearse.
You know how many people you know want
to look in the front of the Hong Kong?
That's brilliant.
That's fucking brilliant.
So you were driving around in a scam car.
Why?
I knew that the police started
to pull that thing over and he,
that's a little areas,
but do you muscly look to
Ferrari's and Lamborghini's?
God Damn,
I could just go buy one of those.
Oh my guys handled,
you know,
if I want to go out in the Ferrari,
I just called one of my guy,
man,
I don't want to use your Ferrari.
We denied.
Oh that's cool.
Yo Yo yo a vet.
You the headaches,
right?
I ain't got to put it up.
I ain't got to watch you get so smart.
That's amazing.
It just,
it just started coming,
you know,
just little by little,
some say no,
no way.
No jury.
Because if you wear jewelry,
everybody gonna know you sell drugs.
I didn't want,
my Mama didn't know I sold drugs.
What did you tell your mom you were doing?
I mean I didn't,
you know,
she,
when she found out I had all that money,
man,
she
one day,
uh,
cause my spot is,
it's like my spot was like two,
two or three miles from my house.
So what I would do is I would go to the
spot work and every time I'd get like
2000 I'd run to the house and put
it up and went back to the track.
Cause you don't want to be standing out
on the track with too much money because
the police come over with man.
When you get to $3,000
what you doing on wall?
This money problems.
So what I would do is every time I'd get
a couple of thousand dollars I'd run to
the house and put it up.
So my mom see me keep
running in the house,
you know,
back and forth back and will want it all.
I'm doing this all day.
All night.
I don't do nothing else.
I ain't got a girlfriend.
I'm single.
Right,
right.
This is my love is to be out on the track.
I'm doing this 1819 hours a day.
Wow.
Sleeping.
Jumped right back yet.
Yeah.
All the time.
Are you sleeping?
You losing?
Sometimes I sleep in the car on the smile,
you know?
Wow.
With something with Shit on you.
Just a little bit though.
You packing a gun or when
I got my boy standing out,
he's standing back like [inaudible]
we stand out on the street and we cut,
we call the curve servant.
Now I would be standing out on the curb
and then he would be sitting like in
somebody's yard with the pistol.
So if somebody got at me
or something like that,
then he would just bust
out and start running.
Right.
So He's,
he's from a different vantage points that
not even seeing him as a point and see
him.
It's like the police,
if the police come in and re they going
to grab us standing out on the block and
they're not going to bother him
because he's up in somebody's yard.
So,
you know,
we had a little crazy
system that we had lined up,
man.
That's brilliant.
So,
um,
you,
you had a spot was like,
like on a street corner
or something like that.
Like there was an area that first,
soon 81st in between Hoover in Vermont.
It was like apartment complexes,
you know,
a bunch of apartment complexes.
And how do you get a spot?
Like,
what do other dudes try
to move in on your spot?
Because they know that
everybody goes there to buy.
Well,
at that time nobody was trying to move
in on my spot because nobody really could
get the cocaine.
They didn't,
they didn't know how valuable cocaine was.
They didn't really,
really,
I had abandoned the spot when
other guys started coming in.
You know,
I had gotten so big,
so I didn't stay on the street song
cause I took all my money and parlayed it
back into the game.
So I got big so fast that I was able
to then start selling these guys,
uh,
three grams and then they
would go out and sell it.
And I was just making like 50,
$75 off every three grams
that I would sell them.
And that started to be so much money
that I didn't even need to s ill 50s and
hundreds.
Right.
So people just,
they became,
they became a,
you were like the main dude
in everybody sold it for you.
Right.
So then where did you keep everything?
Did you have like a warehouse?
Like,
how did you uh,
have it set up so you could,
well,
eventually what I did is I set up spots,
like say for instance if you eventually,
when I got real big,
I have like $50 spots
and if you go to my spot,
him Smith,
$50 would be like going to somebody
else's spot and spend $100.
You could do what they call double up.
You could double your money.
You buy $50 worth,
you can make 50 more.
Now if you would go there and you start
buying those 50s and you get up to
spending 2000 then the people at that
house will take you to another house where
you would have to come there and spend
2000 then if you got up to buy a 10,000
then you would get to go to another house
and then we'd have a lot of these $50
houses.
They would be just all over the place
and then it would just be a 50 to a few,
$2,000 spots and then it will
be even less $10,000 spot.
Do you know this is all for distributors,
right?
This is all for distributed.
So you had like distributing houses.
You had like a whole tier system,
right?
Absolutely.
Brilliant.
I didn't know,
I didn't know exactly what,
you know,
what the,
how they call it at the time,
but I knew,
see when I'd be in,
as I dealt with people the way
I want it to be dealt with,
I knew the problem that I
had when I was coming up,
so I tried to cut out all
their problems for them.
I didn't want them to have to
deal with none of the headaches,
you know,
not worrying about how to cook it,
how to get it at,
at a safe price,
how to make sure that the place was safe.
I took care of all that form.
When they came to me,
they knew they was going
to get their proper stuff.
They knew they weren't going to be robbed,
they knew how they would
be able to re up again.
Everything was was like
cookie cutter form almost.
Wow.
That's amazing.
So you're doing this for eight years,
you said from the beginning it was crazy.
But when,
when did you start getting legal problems?
Yeah,
my problem starting around 86.
How many years in was that?
Six years.
Six.
Six w what was it they
started arresting you?
They started asking me what
you're getting money you taskforce
man.
They started to go crazy first day.
Uh,
they started to raised spots that
we didn't even sell drugs that,
you know,
he started writing my girlfriend's
houses and planting drugs on them.
You know,
cause I don't even keep drugs in my
girlfriend's house cause I stayed there,
you know.
But those were the easiest
spots to figure out.
You know,
where that we're connected to them.
You know where people came over,
cause they will let their friends
come over like my workspot.
You didn't come to my workspot.
It listen,
you sold drugs when no need
for you coming over there.
Don't even,
you know it only Max what asked that.
Right.
So they,
they raided my girlfriend's houses and
then they would take them to jail for
drugs and stuff like that there.
So I'm like,
wow.
So then they started to getting my guys,
you know,
they started to catch,
my guy's driving down the street and
they plant drugs on them and it just got
really crazy until it got to a
point where one night I'm uh,
coming from a basketball gym.
I'm gonna Adjust your mic real quick.
Okay.
It makes a big difference.
Yeah.
All right.
Okay.
There we go.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
I'm riding down the street one day and
my,
and my guys and we say,
man,
look at all the homies
over there playing dice.
So they was at my tire shop.
So we jump out and go buy Holler at him,
you know,
see who went into crap game.
And when we get rid of the leave
the whole crap game come with me.
You know,
like it's,
it's 10,
11 o'clock at night.
So they all want to walk me out to the
car and make sure everything is cause
it's so I jumped in the car and pull off
and I look in the rear view mirror and
it's a car following me with no lights on.
So we are going to high speed chase,
no chase for a few minutes.
Do the hoods,
trying to lose them.
And then I look up cars
all around us coming.
Pot Lights pop in on,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm like,
Oh man,
set up.
So,
uh,
I wound up getting out the car,
jumping out the car,
leave the car rolling and
jump out and get away.
Well,
they shooting at meat,
police,
Bam,
Bam.
But it's wisdom across my head and
the whole nine yards and I get away.
So once I get away,
the next morning,
my lawyer called me and said,
man,
you had a,
you have two kilos of
cocaine on you that night.
I said,
man,
I ain't had no cocaine that night.
He said,
yeah,
they,
they uh,
they said you had two keys of
cocaine and you shot at the police.
So,
uh,
my mom called me,
you know,
she's crying.
All the police been by
here and raided the house,
had everybody outside handcuffed and sent,
ain't gonna kill you.
Why don't you turn yourself in?
So her and my lawyer who convinced
me to turn myself in and we go in,
we fight the case.
I want a beaten it though,
because the dogs all planet,
you know how to approve the drug supplier,
man.
It was,
it was hard.
You know what I'm saying?
I,
I stayed in jail for a while,
no bail.
They had me on $1 million bail,
1251 where all the property and everything
had to be inspected and make sure it
wasn't drug proceeds and,
and all that.
Man.
It was crazy going through all that.
But,
um,
while I was in jail,
the cops come down to my
sale to interrogate me.
So they pulled me out the cell,
take me to the back of the jail.
You know,
what they,
what people were up in and stuff.
And I'm starting asking me a bunch of
crazy questions about drugs and all this,
and by my lawyer,
you know,
jewelry should have let you take the deal.
Who Know why he thinks are
going to fight this case.
You ain't going to win.
We always get our man.
So during this time that
they interviewed me,
they recording everything
and at the end of the,
the interrogation,
they told me,
you better not tell your lawyer what
happened if we find out that you told him
we're going to,
uh,
we're going to take care of you.
So I don't even tell my lawyer.
So we get to court.
The next time we go to court in a,
they got the guy on the witness stand,
he's testifying.
I said,
man,
you know,
that guy came down and
see me like two weeks
to go.
And so he thinking that I ain't
doing to tell my lawyer never.
Right.
So my lawyer springing on him like,
man,
you was at the county jail
a couple of weeks ago.
He was like,
yeah,
cause you know he signed in.
So he knew he had to say,
yeah.
He said,
you saw my client?
He's like,
yeah.
He said,
you knew he had a lawyer then you need,
he's like,
yeah,
I knew he had a lawyer and then
want you to be calling all the,
all the conversations when a,
when you interview suspects.
He said,
yeah,
I want that tape.
He said,
young,
I want that tape.
So they parked,
bought the tape in the tape was all
spiced up and cut up and he raised and all
kinds of stuff.
So the judge was like,
man,
get this case out of here.
Really?
But what they did is they took it to
the feds and had the feds to indict me
without the tape,
you know,
like that.
And also take,
you know,
they never told the feds about the tape.
So the tape.
So the feds indict me for that case,
but then when they do,
I had hired a private investigator to
invest the cops then investigate the
couch.
Then we show them,
hey look,
when we got on them and you see you guys
don't want to use them as witnesses.
Awesome.
What'd you get on them?
Oh man,
we had him beaten people planting drugs.
150 people got released from prison
behind those cops doing what they did
with a lot of people don't realize is
how deep corruption is and some police
forces,
especially in Los Angeles,
a certain point in time,
especially like the Rampart district,
like people don't even know the story
behind that was a criminal gang.
Now
part was a a fall off from
the freeway task force.
Really?
Yeah.
Freeway task force was the
beginning of that whole thing.
The freeway task force was
the most elite task force in,
in,
in the country.
Just to get you just to give it.
Wow.
I feel fortunate.
I mean,
what's crazy means you're out now,
is it feel weird to be how
many guys on the story?
How many guys get their own task force?
They're very few.
It was like one in a billion.
You get you a little wrapper puppet,
you know
he got a freeway task force,
rapper,
puppet.
You lived a fucking charm life.
You still $600 million with a coke yet
out on the street and now might be fun to
get a jet.
Wow.
You might get a judge.
Yeah.
What do you mean in this case?
You know,
this judge might,
I don't know which case
there's Rick Ross case.
Yeah.
You,
you think the judge is corrupt?
I don't know.
Are you investigating this judge?
I am.
Yeah.
I think you should.
I want to know how she came
to a conclusion as you know,
why?
Why did you,
yeah,
those are ridiculous conclusions.
Exactly.
So I want to get to the bottom of,
I'm going get to the bottom of it,
you know,
anything that we can talk about it.
Right.
And she a Freemason little bit.
A little bit.
You know,
he ain't no free mason,
you know,
free mason donation.
She means the judge.
Yeah.
Day.
He's not either,
supposedly wasn't supposed
to be a Freezeman rapper.
Yeah.
Rick was supposed to be a free man.
He said that before,
but you don't call him.
What the fuck is his name again?
Uh,
Billy Bob.
It's called fat bill.
So fat bill is supposed
to be a Freemason too.
I don't know.
He said it on a couple of
songs or something like that.
Wow.
Okay.
But I know the masons are
not really happy with it.
Oh really?
That's hilarious.
They contacted me.
They're not happy with that at all.
Wow.
So you,
you get arrested.
So eventually,
how do you,
how do you wind up getting taken down?
You got through all this,
you got to this one case where they
tried to plant two kilos on you were Mo,
most supplier Danilo blend.
Dawn,
he brings me down.
He bring me down your
supplier probably down.
This was the Nicaraguan guy.
He brought me down.
He gave you up,
gave me up
and this is never heard me.
Oh,
and this is while the Oliver North Shit,
all that was going down.
It was just before that.
I think it was after that.
That was after all.
He had gotten his,
pardon?
I need a part until anybody out there
know Obama and tell him I'm looking for,
I did my part.
I mean why should I get
a library like Reagan?
Hilarious and so true too.
Right?
If you really find out if you,
I mean people think that this is nonsense.
You know,
the,
the connection between the CIA and
selling drugs has been pretty well
documented.
Go look up a case on a
guy named Barry seal.
Barry CEO was a guy out of MENA,
Arkansas who was,
by the way,
there's Bill Clinton's
fucking stomping grounds.
That's where they were dropping coke.
They were flying cocaine from South
America and they were dropping it off in
Mena,
Arkansas.
And the story goes to kids see the drop,
uh,
they catch the kids and kill them and
then they put the kids on the train tracks
and say that the kids fell asleep on
train tracks and they were high and they
fell asleep and they
got run over by trains.
So the parents do an autopsy on the
bodies and they find Kneifel loans.
Wow.
So they find out,
no,
no.
These kids were murdered.
That go into the story.
It turns out Barry seal's gets busted
because it was his plane that was coming
in at that time.
And then they find out about the coke
and he gives up all the information they
want up assassinating him when
he was on his way to trial.
Well,
man,
Gary Webb killed himself,
shot himself in the head twice,
twice with a shotgun.
So was it a shotgun?
He shot himself in the head twice.
Well,
thanks.
So I am sorry to reports,
but I think this would,
somebody said it was a shot gun.
Wow.
Yeah.
Shoot yourself in the head twice.
It seems like that's what I didn't do.
The job you had a job to do
and you didn't finish it.
So it doesn't seem to make sense to me.
Take care of it.
I've heard it's possible to
shoot yourself in the head twice,
but you know,
that's also the dude who was
the whistle blower for Enron.
Shot himself in the head twice.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
And then not too suspicious.
Right,
right.
This gigantic multibillionaire scam goes
down one motherfucker starts ratting
people out and winds up shooting
in a car twice in the head.
Wow.
Really?
How many people have committed
suicide by gunshot to the head?
Twice.
I mean,
I've seen people get knocked out with
like a little bitty punch and you tell me
you shoot it yourself and you're
awake after they had good willpower.
Yeah.
Yes.
Makes you the job was done well.
I guess if you had any strength left,
if you shot yourself in the head and
you realize you were still alive,
you had any strength left,
you would probably shoot yourself a car.
You know,
he'd be like,
what the fuck?
I'm going to just bleed
out here in the car,
man.
This Americans buy anything.
Yeah.
So you do you think
Gary Webb was murdered?
I mean his book,
dark alliance.
Essentially what happened is it started
out a bunch of articles written for the
San Jose Mercury News and it was later
published as a book and the three part
series he investigated
the Nicaraguan linked,
uh,
to the CIA back contrast who had allegedly
slipped and it's like he exposed the
whole thing and brought the Reagan
administration and delight and expose them
for essentially being drug dealers.
Absolutely.
Gary was amazing man.
I mean,
you know,
he's the one who stopped
the forfeiture laws,
you know,
that you said would take your property
before you were found guilty of a drug
crime.
And Gary made them stop that and saying,
hey,
at least you got to take this guy to
try and find out he was selling drugs
before you take his property.
Well,
that's before they would
take your property,
sell it,
and then you get kicked out of prison.
You never got convicted.
And they'd be like,
Oh,
well your car is gone.
Well,
what's hilarious?
Yeah.
What's hilarious is if you look at,
uh,
how the Patriot Act has been used,
you know how many times the Patriot Act
has actually been used for terrorism.
It's a tiny,
tiny,
tiny fraction because the Patriot Act
classifies drug selling as terrorism.
So the Patriot Act has been used for
drug selling thousands of times and it's
been used for terrorism,
like a small handful.
It's,
it's kind of cute.
It's kind of cute.
Have they've figured out how
to circumvent the system?
Absolutely.
I mean,
it's crazy the way.
Uh,
um,
I saw a thing on CNN the other night and
they were talking about how California
has built so many prisons and absolutely
no colleges in the past 10 years.
And I'm like,
I mean this is what happened
to an ounce of prevention.
You know,
we're going with pounds and tons of cure,
but no prevention.
Well the worst thing that ever happened,
that could be possible.
They made private presence.
They made it profitable for
people to put people in jail,
which is fucking insane.
The fact,
I mean that is,
that's some Orwellian Shit.
That's some,
that's some shit that should have been
taking place is slavery is slavery.
It's 100% slavery.
Especially when you
have certain government
organizations that lobby to keep
certain things illegal like drug selling,
like nonviolent crimes,
like nonviolent drug offenses.
When you're,
you're telling someone that they don't
have control over their own consciousness
and because they don't agree with
you as to what they can and can't do,
you're going to lock them in
a cage and profit from it.
That's amazing.
It's a great business that
somebody fucking amazing
though that in 2012 with are
all the access to information
we have today that
that's still a legal thing.
I mean,
it's just another piece of perfect advice
or are perfect information rather than
shows,
shows you how corrupt the system is.
Yeah,
it's,
it's incredible.
It's incredible when you really stop
and think about how many prisoners are,
are good that we got people like
you to bring this stuff to light.
I mean,
I don't see why more,
more people don't stand up.
You know what,
I guess people saw what happened
to Gary and you're like,
Shit.
Yeah,
right.
Me,
me go out there and put my job on the
line and my family wellbeing I to expose
shit that's already banks beaus that's,
I'm,
I come in like third,
fourth,
fifth,
sixth.
I'm not the number one
guy breaking the news.
So you make sure he's safe.
Shit's already clear.
It's already on the Internet.
By the time I hear about it,
I'm like a third hand reporter.
Somebody finds it on the Internet.
They tweet me.
I find out about,
I go with it.
But,
uh,
I actually found out about you
through Kevin boost documentary.
Um,
uh,
the,
the great white hope,
American drug war.
Kevin's a good guy.
Kevin.
Uh,
you know,
kept an eye on me when I was in prison,
wrote me,
I could call Kevin.
He interviewed you from prison as well?
He did.
When I met with Kevin,
Kevin made my life a little
easier while I was in prison.
You know,
shout out to Kevin Booth.
Kevin produced my first DVD.
Oh,
Daddy's comedy DVD.
I sent the book,
I read the book that uh,
he,
he his buddy road.
Bill Hicks.
Yeah.
Kevin's a good guy though.
Yeah,
he,
uh,
he became mean who he is because
of his friendship with Bill Hicks.
You know,
he used to follow Bill Hicks around and
record them and Bill Hicks as far as
standup comedians are concerned,
like one of the top 10 greatest
comedians of all time for sure.
You know,
right up there with a lot of
people like Richard Pryor.
Right.
Even though he didn't live very long died
of pancreatic cancer when he's only in
his young thirties,
you know.
But,
um,
so he creates this,
this documentary,
the American drug war.
And that's,
that's how I heard about you.
And,
and that's how I heard about,
cause I had already,
I had already heard about Barry seals and
Barry seal and his connection with the
CIA and selling drugs.
But I didn't,
I didn't know of any one person like you
who could be directly connected to the
dude that was connected to Nicaragua that
was connected to Oliver North and the
whole chain of events.
Absolutely.
I think when,
uh,
window,
when blend on testified against me,
he talked about
his balls to going on a fishing
ship with a George Bush senior.
Wow.
When the kid went,
Barry seal was murdered,
he had George Bush,
his phone number in his pocket
as deep as it gets.
Might've been a tracking
device in that phone number.
Yeah,
I know where you at.
And then meanwhile,
and meanwhile,
no one goes to jail.
No one on that side goes to jail.
Nothing.
No one goes to jail.
I should day.
It's amazing they make the laws,
but how the fuck did
they let you out at work?
Yeah.
They only you,
you went in for 20 years.
I had a life sentence,
man.
And how'd you get out early?
Learning how to read and
write and the law and
a loophole.
What was the little fall?
Well,
what they did is they charged
me under the three strike law.
And uh,
what they were saying is that since I
had got convicted and all these different
states,
that those added up to three strikes.
But what they didn't see in the,
in the law is that in
order to get struck out,
you have to go to prison,
get out,
they commit another crime,
go to prison,
get out and then commit the third one.
And that's three strikes.
So we can't get you on three felonies
before you're ever convicted.
Three strikes,
three strikes if,
if,
if safe is,
and what I use is,
is a guy standing out when I
used to stand out on the street,
I used to make hundreds of sales a
day right there on that one block.
So I said no.
If somebody wanted to,
they could've gave me
a hundred convictions.
Right?
Cause I'm with different
people every time.
So I didn't believe that the law meant
that every sale you may was a separate
conviction.
I believe that they meant just like
I just explained it because if so,
then everybody who ever sold cocaine,
what happened?
Three strikes and it makes sense
because the idea is supposed to be
theoretically that jail is supposed
to be able to really rehabilitate.
Yeah,
exactly.
So if you are unreliability table,
if you've gone through two separate
times and you're still out doing the same
shit,
all right,
well this dude's a career criminal.
This is his third offense done.
That makes sense.
And that's how the law was rolled up.
Even though I don't believe you should
play baseball with people lives.
Right.
Because the person could not be changed
at one time and then be changed tomorrow
and then his circumstances changed
and he may be in a different position.
Right.
You know,
before you can start passing judgment,
judgment on people,
you have to live in their shoes and,
and you know,
that's why people ask me now,
how do I feel about
drug dealers and other,
I ain't got none.
He him,
right.
They do.
What they feel like they got to do
or what they know they got to do.
So,
uh,
before we pass judgment,
we have to get all the facts and live in
that person's shoes to see if we would
do the same thing that they did.
And you're a perfect example of that.
Absolutely.
Now you,
you're away.
You went away for 20 years,
you find this loophole.
How deep into your sentence had you
had already figured out how to read?
How
I started reading immediately right away.
Yeah.
Take classes there and no,
I taught my,
me and my celly,
he taught me how to read.
He made me some cue cards
to my ABC's on them,
a call and went from,
from nose to a reading my indictment
to reading the newspapers to uh,
to read law books.
I mean,
you know,
for the first time when I found out is
that I had never wanted to read before in
my life.
That was the real problem.
I never really wanted to read.
I mean,
I didn't see any reason why Jack and
Jill went up the hill and why I should
know.
Right.
You know what I'm saying?
They didn't have it when Jason,
no money.
I was chasing money.
Right,
right,
right.
It was,
it wasn't interesting to you.
It wasn't interesting to me.
But then once you realize,
well,
there's a lot of that I don't have access
to.
I gotta I gotta I became an avid reader.
I read over 300 books
before I left prison.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
You've read more books
than I have in my lifetime.
Yeah.
So you're in prison,
you're,
you're learning how to read.
At what point in time did
you start devising a plan
to try to like figure out a
way to get out of there?
Well,
immediately I was trying to get out,
you know,
I knew that the guys that
were going home was it guys.
It was going to the library,
learn how to become lawyers,
you know,
they knew how to fight the system and
then they had like guys that all they did
all day was sit down and study law.
You know,
they would sit at a table while the
people were playing cards and chest and
Domino's.
They will be studying the law.
So I got,
I got in with those guys.
That's gotta be kind of a crazy feeling,
man.
Everybody's just hoping you can crack
this fucking system that's got you locked
up.
It's tough.
Starts to hurt daily.
You get,
you got like migraine headaches and
you sitting in this concrete building,
I'm going to try to
draw a picture for you.
You sitting in this concrete
building is 28 stories high,
um,
nothing but concrete and steel.
The windows are about three inches
wide open and about six feet long
escape.
It looks almost impossible when you know,
you think about that too.
Like if I had a long rope pocket scale,
the side of the building,
so,
uh,
it's like a desperation,
you know,
and you saying,
man,
it gotta be one loophole in
his books because you know
that if
you can show them in the book where
they made a mistake or would a book says
that they should have did
this when they did that,
then you know,
you got the action.
So you're,
you,
you get any headaches just from
thinking and reading too much.
Yeah,
that's all you want to do.
And you just want to stand them books.
You know,
I got a life sentence.
when you've got a life sentence,
it's like this is forever.
You know,
this is all you're going to
see for the rest of your life,
you know?
So,
um,
I didn't think that was fitting for me.
It's amazing that they convicted you
for life on that three strikes law.
It seems like you should be able to
go after them for abusing the law,
which should be criminal.
Well,
you can't,
you can't go at the federal prosecutor.
He's immune.
That's amazing.
From,
from,
from prosecution because he,
he's not working as an individual.
Even if it's been proven
that he's corrupt.
Well,
maybe if you can pull he's,
he's corrupt,
but not because he incompetent and justly.
Yeah.
In combination.
In your case,
you know,
if he does something to you,
you could charge you with a thousand keys,
even though you only had one know.
And if you've got a thousand keys,
you know,
that gives you a life sentence.
If you got one,
you know,
you can get probation.
But uh,
if it's powder,
that's it.
That's a thing people don't know about.
That's another good point because crack
was in the ghetto and powder was all
these,
you know,
other people,
these people that had money
were using the powder.
Crack is way more illegal.
Yeah.
Honey bird tube one.
Wow.
That's incredible.
That is,
is that racist?
Very racist.
And it has to be right.
And I think,
I mean,
and even though they
just change it 18 to one,
I think that was still,
why isn't it a one to one?
And that's when I say it
because they already proved,
you know,
I sit down on the couch with
the guy who invented the law.
Really?
Yeah.
It's going to be in the
document and Mi six,
six,
six documentary after you're out.
You sat down with that.
Yeah,
I've been doing that since I've been out.
I've been doing a documentary
since I've been out man.
And,
and,
and one of the things that I got
mad about even with Obama and his
administration is that they
didn't make it one on one.
And then even after they made an 1801
they left it for guys who have been in 20
years,
25 years,
they didn't make it retroactive.
Meaning that they don't get out.
They don't get no benefit
from the front of 18 to one.
It's guys right now,
if they,
if they had the 18 to one,
they will walk out of prison today.
Wow.
So I'm saying if it's wrong today and
you did it 20 years ago was wronged in,
right.
But they said,
oh well there they lost their,
uh,
cause you know,
Clinton signed a bill where you're 2155,
you've got one year after you convicted
to come up with newly discovered
evidence and the law.
It's crazy man.
Like right now,
say for instance,
if you go to prison unjustly and you
do all your appeals and everything one
year,
you have one year to
prove yourself innocent.
Now after that one year,
if you don't find it and then a day
after that one year you find this newly
discovered evidence,
you can't even submit it to the coach.
Oh that's gotta be maddening.
It's maddening.
They got guys in there that,
that,
that found newly discovered evidence that
they can't even submit it for anybody
to hear it.
So when you went to jail for this
and when you're finally in prison,
was there,
there,
was this the first time you'd ever been
in prison other than the one time you
got arrested and you
stayed in there for awhile?
No,
no,
I,
that was my second time when
I got the life sentence.
I've been to jail twice.
So you had two strikes,
you had one,
Stryker.
Stryker,
right.
How long did you go
away for the first time?
Five and a half years.
Wow.
So you were in the second time?
I was in trapped.
I didn't even go into that point when
I was in trap cause I wasn't selling
drugs.
I was building a youth center because
when I did is I figured out what kids in
the ghetto need to get them
out of gangs and drugs.
I know what they need.
So when I did is I bought a new,
I'm born at the aid,
they need some,
some,
some instructions.
They need somebody to come and,
and,
and walk them through it.
Somebody they can go and talk to
when they need to talk to him,
you know,
not talk to him once they already been
corrupted and there he is already in the
game.
They don't want to hear you then,
you know,
I already got my mind made up.
I know what I'm doing.
I'm my own man.
But before they get like that,
they need somebody,
a place that they can go and,
and they could talk to Joe Rogan or Rick
Ross or magic Johnson or Oprah Winfrey
or some of these other people who could
teach them how to make money other ways,
you know,
because in,
in the ghetto,
you know,
the first business you see in the ghetto,
you know the first is what
the drug man,
he's going to be the first
businessman that you see in,
in south central Los Angeles is going to
be the drug man and especially a black
man as a business owner because we don't,
we don't,
nothing in south central.
So you,
when you got,
so you said you got set up.
This is the last time.
Yeah.
When I got the life sentence,
this guy called me.
I'm not selling drugs.
He was selling drugs or on him.
I had,
I hadn't sold drugs and six years,
seven years.
Wow.
How did you stop?
I just quit.
Did you quit after you got arrested?
The first time in the five years I
quit a year and a half before I went to
prison.
I was like,
man,
I'm through with this.
I got,
I've got eight $900,000 cash.
I've got property all over the place and
I got to do now is make this property
and stuff work for me and you know I've
got enough money to hold me off for
awhile.
I'm through with it.
So I walked away from the game.
So I'm confused as on your timeline
here because when you were 20 years old,
that's when you started and then
when you were 28 you got arrested.
Right?
But you did five years in jail,
right?
Where's the five years?
I did the five years
in 89 I went to prison.
How old were you then?
28 28 and a half.
28 and a half.
You go to jail for five years
and then you get out for,
I got out,
I got off for six months for six
months and then they give you the life
sentence,
right?
Whoa,
God damn.
So the life sentences,
a total setup.
Total setup to trap me,
total entrapment.
I was not selling drugs
and then they'll call me.
And a matter of fact called
me the day I got a prison.
Whoa.
He was like,
man,
I need to see you
like,
man,
I'm kicking it with my mom.
You know,
my mom came and see me
and stuff like that.
So I'm not going to
kicking it with my mom.
I'm cool.
I hydrogen a couple of days.
So when I finally going to
highlight and he's telling me,
Oh man,
I got it at this price
and kind of at that price,
I was like,
what?
That's a good one.
Right?
And all this is recorded too.
So that didn't help.
You know,
they was like,
oh,
well you were interested.
Wow.
So,
uh,
this went on for six
months that he courted me,
you know,
calling me,
dropping the price,
driving a motherfucker.
And then
one day he caught me and I was
riding with one of my little homies,
Chico Brown.
I said,
man,
this dude just told me,
whoo.
When she goes,
look man,
I can sell all that
then that,
that's how I got started.
So I wind up making an
introduction to the two of them.
Chico hand in the money and the
police come from everywhere.
So you'd never even got to sell?
No,
I never sold it.
So this guy,
where is he now?
Danilo.
Uh,
he's in Nicaragua.
Just chilling.
He's supposed to be in the
documentary to really yell.
Y'all better check that documentary out.
It's going to be awesome.
Now this Danilo him.
We don't have to cop that plan,
didn't you?
Hugs.
Whoa.
It's,
do you have proof that
he planted the drugs?
I know he plans a drunk.
Does he?
He went to,
no,
I don't think he's
to mini plans to drove,
but he went to jail for it.
He went to jail for planting
those drugs for corruption.
You know,
beaten people plan dre.
He was doing,
I don't police it was a habit.
I mean he made money,
man.
Yeah,
well that's where the rampart comes in.
I mean for people don't know.
Most.
Most police officers at this point in
time believe that should night hired cops
to kill biggie smalls and that,
um,
they also,
he probably also had Tupac killed
and that he did it all under this,
under this rampart division.
It's rampart division was working for him.
I mean there's a huge rolling
stone article about it.
It's fascinating,
fascinating shit that the cops were so
dirty that the cops were working with
gang members.
They're working with murderers,
working with criminals and
making money clearly profiting.
Well,
you know,
cops man,
they just like everybody else,
you know,
they lie,
cheat and all other things that the
normal person goes through in life.
So I don't put nothing past him,
especially when you start putting
all that money on the table.
You know,
I remember my first young guy who got
arrested by him and they stole his money.
He was like 16 years old and he called me,
he was like,
quick man,
the cops just raided my house.
I was like,
yeah,
you are.
I,
and he's like,
yeah,
I'm cool.
And I was like,
what'd you ask him?
He's like,
man,
I had like $40,000.
I said,
what happened?
He said,
man,
they asked me who money was
and I told him it wasn't mine.
They told me to go.
Wow.
So when he got out,
when I got with him,
you know we call the lawyer,
you're told the lawyer you.
Amen.
It was $40,000 at that house,
but with no drug.
So he called and they said,
man,
with no money at that house.
Wow.
That's super common,
right?
Yeah.
That happened all the time.
There's no one policing the police.
There's no one governing the government.
That's the real issue.
They got the beginner,
they got the guns.
Well,
not only that,
they can change the laws.
I mean we see what the fuck is
going on now with this country.
It was like every week
they'd come up with some new,
even more restrictive,
even more or welling law that gets through
that allows them to tap your phones
with no wire,
with no warrants.
Rather,
you know,
listening on your phone calls,
tap your fucking gps systems that
could follow everywhere you go.
And they can do all this
shit without warrants.
Now.
I mean,
and they do it supposedly
under the guise of terrorism,
but it's really under the guise of making
it easier for them to prosecute you
for whatever the fuck they want to cause
there's a God damn business and locking
people up in cages.
Exactly.
So that's what they into their new role.
So you find your whole loophole
and then you chase after it,
you're in jail.
Right.
And then once you,
once you find it,
Luke,
remember that day when
I read it in the book,
you knows like me,
he just like popped out at me.
Boom,
go to jail,
commit a crime and get released.
I sat to the phone to call my lawyer.
I see,
man,
I found it.
Wow.
So what happens then
where it was discouraging
what he said after he read it.
He see it the same way I did.
You're a better lawyer than your
fucking lawyer come Harvard.
Why?
I should get an honorary degree.
Yeah.
So I just told him to
do or put on the books,
you know,
then the judge went through her thing.
Oh No,
Mr. Ross,
not the way you said it is.
And I was like,
can she must came read if she
can't read that she can't read.
So then the prosecutor went
through his whole thing,
but then I went to the Ninth Circuit
Court of Appeals and they agree with me.
Totally.
You know,
say that uh,
if they,
uh,
did it the way they were saying do it did,
they would lock up.
Everybody would be career
criminals on their first arrest.
So
yeah.
Literally everybody would be in life.
Here I am life.
Here I am.
Wow.
So nice sort of ninth
circuit court of Appeals.
They agree with you.
They side with you.
You released immediately.
No,
and I had nine more years to do,
man.
Jesus Christ.
Why nine more years?
Uh,
that's just where it was,
you know,
that's how much time I had left.
Okay.
So you had $20.
They cut me down.
No,
no.
I had a life,
but they talked me down to 20.
So the Ninth Circuit Court of
Appeals cut you down a 20 Oh,
okay.
So at least you knew there was a light
at the end of the tunnel that right,
right.
So then I was happy with that.
You were happy with that?
Yeah.
I was going to lead a penitentiary
cause I was up in Lompoc penitentiary,
you know,
USP Lompoc that help.
What does that place like?
Oh man,
that's a dungeon.
You know everybody in there,
I've got 40 years of better.
You know,
they mad at you or if you got 20 you know,
they got to get you out
of there with 20 years.
You know something might happen to you.
Really,
man.
Yeah.
That was kind of 21 years.
Freedom is you're almost free.
Yeah.
You gotta,
you gotta walk on egg shells around here.
If you have 20 inches and you've
got between you and you to going,
wait a minute,
how they talk to him,
they were like mad at you
or they'd be mad at you.
They're mad at you.
If you only got 20 years.
Yeah,
that's,
you got 30 years,
they might be mad.
God.
Damn.
That's hilarious.
Hilarious.
I mean,
you can get hurt,
you can get hurt then just
because you got 20 years.
How did you stay out of danger?
Well,
uh,
like I said,
when I got my time cut,
I only had to stay there like three
more months and I was out of there.
So it was easy for me.
And,
and you know,
I'm aware like guy to jail.
Yeah.
They liked me and I get hers.
Was the prison that you were in initially,
the first president
before they moved you out?
Oh Man.
I saw guys get hit in the
head with a on mock ringers.
Iron.
What?
Mock ringers.
Wring the mop out.
It's this great big old thing.
My way about 1520 pounds.
Yeah.
You know the guy sitting in his chair
and the guy walks up behind him and just
smashes a score with it.
I mean,
brutal,
brutal site.
I seen a guy get beat with a baseball
bat and aluminum baseball bat into his
head.
It was like mush.
They had to helicopter him
out when the helicopter,
I think he had brain damage stolen.
He didn't,
you know,
was a vegetable.
Uh,
I've seen guys get stabbed.
You know what,
I'm taking a shower and you know,
you hear this loud noise,
like just keep bumping
up against the wall,
boom,
boom.
Really violently,
you know,
and you know,
this is somebody's body,
you know,
like why would somebody be
hitting the wall this hard?
You know?
And uh,
so I,
I wrap my towel up and I looked my head
out the shower when I see this guy and
this guy stabbing him.
And so to get off tonight,
he's just throwing this back and
hitting everything up against the wall,
trying to get away from the knife.
So what's really violent?
I mean,
prison is really violent.
You know,
you,
you have to be careful,
especially in the USP,
the USP.
But no one was a dangerous too,
but not as dangerous as USP because
these guys don't have nothing to,
what does a USP us penitentiary,
penitentiary.
What is the difference?
Well say for instance,
the FCI,
you can't have more than
20 years and be at the FCI.
If you have more than 20 stands for
a federal correctional institution,
that's like a medium.
Okay.
So if you could have more than than,
than than 20 years,
you're going to go to a USP.
Now,
if you go to a FCI and
you've got 20 years,
but you keep getting into trouble
fights and you know something,
maybe you stab somebody and then they're
going to send you to a USP in the hill.
Okay.
And you go up here,
these guys can handle stabbings.
So they're there,
they'll boost you up.
Then they got what they call it,
a low is for the guys
who got like five years,
six years,
then you go to a low.
So they kind of keep it separated
like that by your violence,
by how much you're getting in trouble,
things like that.
So the a USP is the most dangerous.
That's the most absolutely
absent murderers,
life sentences.
And then they had guys from all over the
country safe and you in Washington DC
and,
and uh,
you been getting in trouble in Washington.
They see then they shipped you down to
California to keep you out of trouble.
And you know,
some of those guys from DC or really,
really violent.
And what they do is they take all the bad,
it's guys from all over the country
and they put them in u s s piece.
So you may have a,
a thing where guys are fighting
over territory like the TV,
you know,
like the DC guys or the
Philadelphia guys might say,
man,
we want to watch this program tonight,
the Philadelphia 76 or the plans.
So we want to watch Philadelphia 76 at
night because you're always watching the
Lakers.
So that could cause a fight.
You know,
it's,
it's kind of like territorial,
you know,
the way it works.
Did you get an anti violence interaction?
Absolutely not.
I said no law library really.
They don't come in a lot.
Librarian fight.
So how did you,
that's how you avoided
everything most of the time.
And the only time I really
would put myself in a,
in,
in harm's way is when,
when football season,
you know,
I played flag football with the guys.
I played basketball with them.
Uh,
but I always had a mentality to,
to,
to diffuse.
Anything that ever happened,
I wouldn't fight.
You know,
if somebody followed me hard
on the basketball court,
it was my fault because I put
myself on the basketball court.
If I find somebody hard
on the basketball court,
it was my fault because I followed him on.
So I would always apologize
to guys when I fired him hard.
But that's just the type of person I am.
You know,
when I played basketball,
I don't mean to hurt anybody,
but sometimes I do.
You know,
I filed a lot,
but,
uh,
um,
I,
you know,
I got along well,
people respected me and
I show up most respect.
Did you have to align yourself
with any groups in prison?
I didn't know.
I didn't even know I am
adopted by a most groups,
you know,
they adopt me.
Most groups.
Yeah.
Most of the groups in Geo adopt me.
You know,
uh,
I mean everybody,
you know,
the Philadelphia guys
that decrypts the bloods,
uh,
did dcs.
I mean I'm cool.
I'm just cold without all of them,
you know.
Uh,
no,
only one property is not,
is,
is um,
what's the,
the cerenia knows and an brothers are
probably the only two groups that,
but it's the Surenos Mexicans.
Yeah.
And then the area in brothers
obviously is kick your kid.
Yeah.
Other than that I got along
and even they got it on,
you know,
they would speak to me,
hey,
you WIC what's happening?
But you know,
we don't hang out.
No,
we didn't know.
Hang out with blacks.
Now
the day you got out of jail,
man,
what the fuck was that like the day you
get out of 20 years knowing that you got
out,
you know,
oh,
hair by hair.
Yeah.
No,
it was luck because,
you know,
it was guys,
when I was in prison it was guys who
had the same issue I had that didn't get
out.
Wow.
They will argue that almost the same way.
You know,
a matter of fact,
we are trying to get the guy who,
uh,
was the first guy to get a life
sentence for selling crack.
We're trying to get his
interview and his issue was,
was almost identical to mine.
Just a little different though,
but close.
And he's,
he's in for life.
He's in it for life and he
was only like 20 years old,
19 years old
and it was the same situation.
They use the three strike rule
and here's the three strike rule.
But he had,
he didn't have three convictions.
His conviction is a little different.
Right.
He,
he,
he did have convictions.
Uh,
he is,
was he,
he went to jail when he was 18 years old.
Okay.
He got out and the same day he got out,
he went right back on the block
and started selling dope again.
And he got arrested that day.
So he wasn't convicted,
he wasn't convicted of the first
one when he caught the second one.
But they said it don't
matter if he was convicted,
you had been to jail so you shouldn't
learn your lesson and you went back out
and you did it again.
Uh,
there's gotta be a lot of that.
He was mad at me when I won.
Really?
Yeah.
And it,
he's supposed to be my man too.
He was mad man.
How you,
when I had to say miss you,
I say no.
You as a little different.
See I never got out on mine.
See on mine,
they took me from,
from,
from La.
They took me to Texas and took me to Ohio.
Took me to St Louis
all
before I ever got released.
I never got released.
Now when you got out was
the first shit he did.
Uh,
you already know,
man.
It's been a long time.
Oh my God,
me saw me.
Old girlfriends.
No,
no new growth.
New Girl in new girl.
Did you know this girl?
The girl's like contact?
Do you like while you're in prison?
Yeah,
I got a lot of matters cause you were
famous famous American gangster magazines
and they knew you were coming
out to as he has magazine year,
they knew I was coming home late day.
They started to publicize
that I had got a date.
Why weren't you the first one
of the first guys to use social?
Like a social mark thing?
Yeah.
I'm the first prison under the start.
A social network freeway
enterprise not come.
Y'all check it out too long.
Right now I'm ranked like
100,000 in the u s uh,
sometimes I go,
I go as little as 70,000.
I'm trying to break down to like 30,000
in the U S and it's called freeway
enterprises.com.
If we were enterprise.com what is
a involved in this social network?
Well when I do is I give people
an outlet for their music,
for the videos.
You know,
like a lot of the sites now they charging
and put the videos up and I don't,
they can put their pictures up,
they can meet friends and she loved
music and she had pictures and,
and just different things.
Uh,
you know,
what they do on the,
on social networks.
So I offer those services for them.
Do you have any insights scoop
on who killed biggie man,
somebody else asked me that.
He said those rolling
stone article read it.
They said the ramp,
our cops did it.
I don't have a clue.
You know,
I was at,
I was at USP Lompoc
when biggie got killed.
I mean I was,
I was disappointed that he came back
to California and I thought that was a
little crazy,
you know,
with what had happened to park.
You know,
I knew that it wasn't safe for him to be
out here in California because guys in
California,
a very revengeful.
And uh,
when I heard that he was in California,
I was like,
what was he thinking about?
It's kind of crazy that musicians started
killing each other and it's been an
amazing,
yeah,
I mean that it never existed.
We were just talking about this when
we were in Atlanta this weekend,
that they were the first
musicians and artists basically,
they would start killing each other.
Wow.
It's Tupac contacted you at all?
Uh,
Nah.
Not recently,
but I'm going to ask you,
did two pot contact him yet?
No,
he hasn't.
Tupac,
you mean the new hologram turned
out that people say Tupacs not dead.
Nobody says that.
That's not an idiot.
A lot of people did like what's his face?
Just said it the other day
and a big music executive.
Uh,
I'll tell you one second one.
Yeah.
This is a photo of him
on the autopsy table.
It's a real simple,
back in the days before they
had Photoshop to Fox dead.
There's no doubt about it.
They killed that dude.
So a,
how many people were a
part of your a freeway?
enterprise.com social media.
I think I got it.
Ride around 16 to 20,000
members right now.
Well,
that's pretty cool.
I'll guarantee you have more today.
I hope so.
I need him.
Y'all sign up,
help you boy it out.
Sign up and also follow him on Twitter.
It's real freeway Ricky on Twitter
and a and and check that out.
Now you are 40,000 followers on Twitter.
Yeah.
You messaged me when
you only had like eight.
I remember u mass and be like,
hi,
getting more followers,
man.
I can't help you.
You know,
man,
I'm,
I'm learning all this social stuff,
all the social media,
but I know they pay so
much attention to them.
Your boy in the backgrounds.
What do you,
what are you asking me?
What's that?
Your,
what'd you say?
His car's parked right there.
Oh,
that's fine.
It's fine.
Oh,
don't worry about it man.
They know this.
They don't do Dina.
Dude.
Nobody's ever put out more music
after their death and Tupac,
right?
Yeah.
Hologram.
Yeah,
it's called Graham was creepy and
just see that shit from Coachella.
Yeah,
I heard about it.
I didn't see it,
but I heard about it.
He's,
it looked like Tupac had
been lifting weights.
Is that right?
Yeah.
They had them all MMA doubt.
He was yoked.
He looked like George St
Pierre was ridiculous.
Seriously.
Had a six pack.
It was,
it was way more muscular
than the regular Tupac.
It was weird.
It was like two pocket just been doing
kettle bells and crossfit and shit.
You know,
who was getting away with food and I mean,
you know,
they don't care who wins the war.
You know,
they got both of them covered.
Biggie and PAC
now record labels nowadays they're fucked.
There's really,
they have to make a percentage of the
artists that are out there performing
live.
Right.
I mean,
how do they make money now?
Yeah,
yeah.
They do the three 60 deals.
Um,
what does that mean when you get
a percentage of everything you do?
You know,
if you do a commercial on TV,
they get a piece of it.
If you a do a contract,
If you get a tennis shoe endorsement,
they want a pizza.
They didn't use to do that.
No,
they didn't.
They used to just be strictly music.
But,
uh,
and what do they always get a
piece of the live performance?
Now they do,
but they didn't always know really.
So this is all post MP three world,
right?
Right.
It used to be like the performance,
you should be all orange.
This is money.
What is the benefit of
having a a music company?
It seems like with the Internet it
would almost be a hindrance to be in
marketing,
marketing down us.
Cause you know,
people believe what they see in here,
but once you get to a point like a
Jay z or somebody who's already in the
contract so he can't get out.
Uh,
but what I was saying is if he started
his own shit and started helping people
promote themselves,
like he starts promoting people,
you could enable people to
become famous on their own.
You think Jessie wants to help people?
Why not?
I mean,
I don't know.
I mean I think that that
then it sounds logical.
Yeah.
If someone explained to him how much
better his own life would be if he helped
other people's lives and it
makes you actually feel better.
Yeah,
he'd probably try it,
but it's hard to saint
that into people's heads.
Everybody's so fucking competitive.
Yeah.
Everybody wants to just
get all the money in,
in,
in Haga foot himself,
and they don't understand that someone
else's success does not equal failure for
you.
It's not like success that was
yours and you didn't get it.
This got,
got it.
It's not like there's only a certain
amount of gold out there and like you,
you're telling people
where the gold is at.
And again,
you're like,
damn,
that could have been my fucking gold.
No,
I mean,
someone else's success has
nothing to do with you.
That's a whole new human being.
Yeah.
It's crazy,
but most people don't want to help.
Nobody.